guest is Michael Val toes he's a 20-year
professional institutional futures
trader from the floor in Chicago started
trading in the CM e trading floor and
later left the open outcry trading pits
and became an electronic trader managed
futures and massive funds for a Commerce
Bank Cargill and most recently eight
years at JPMorgan this is your chance to
learn his order flow concepts which is a
tool that many floor traders used and
was very successful in the floor that's
been one of the few keys that was able
to get people to transfer from the pits
to the screen Michael brings a unique
perspective in order flow analysis and
someone who's traded for living at the
highest institutional level for over 20
years a good friend of mine and a great
trader
welcome to the show Michael hi jack
thanks for having me
hello everybody happy end of the year
you know it's it's not just the end of
the year it's the end of the decade you
know that sort of gets lost in it and
you know it's always a good time at the
end of the year to sort of reflect on
you know how your years been you know
did you reach your goals of where you
want to be and you know I think that you
know when you I sort of look back on my
life over the decades and you know in
the 90s is when I got started basically
in the industry you know on the floor
then you know in the 2000s you know
electronic trading was really picking up
and you know that was sort of like my
you know that's the real work work time
for me and then in the teens I guess it
is the tens 2010 to 2020 is you know I
sort of made the shift out of the
institutional trading started my family
and you know basically trading for
myself and started order flows so I'm
kind of interested in seeing what the
new decade brings and and where I'm
going to go from there for sure I know
you're and I know the people know here
in the event today but you have
extensive experience I mean when it
comes to gurus you have been in Seattle
you've been a floor trader for many
years which I was a floor trader so I
know what that means
and then you successfully made the
change from floor trading to the screen
which I know 97% of the people were
unable to do that and you managed
massive business which I know you
I managed massive business for huge
banks in in the futures markets as well
so I want people to understand that
Michael is somebody who is an absolute
authority figure and has probably traded
I don't even know billions of dollars
total over time and what I really like
about your strategy is the order flows
because it's close to my heart I mean
that's when I was on the floor that's
how I traded and when I left the floor
that's that's what I was trading as well
so I always enjoy your presentations one
thing I want to talk about today because
I know what's on everybody's mind is
this year how do you think volatility
has played into this year and what do
you expect going into 2024 for
volatility and how that's gonna impact
the market well you know it's been an
interesting year actually it's been an
interesting last couple years since
Trump's been presidents and you know I
think next year is gonna be more of the
same you know he just had that
impeachment yesterday and you know the
markets just sort of shrugged it off you
know it's there's you know volatility is
nice it's but it's a two-way sword you
know it's nice you get nice price
movements but at the same time if you're
not careful it can chop you up I and I
don't really foresee the market getting
extremely volatile on honestly that's my
own opinion I mean we've just if you
just look back over the last year you
know so much has happened news cycle
wise that you think oh my gosh this is
it you know and the market keeps making
new eyes you know so unless there's like
some big major catastrophe in the world
I mean hopefully not you know I I
hopefully there's just gonna be more of
the same yep it should be interesting
for sure and you know one thing that you
always talk about is following the the
paper following what people don't know a
paper is it's the big banks the
institutional hedge funds the people
that are trading massive massive funds
what is it just in a general bird's-eye
view what is it about following paper
that in a general sense makes so much
more sense than than most strategies
well you know it's what makes it most
important in my opinion is it shows real
commitment to the market
you know it's somebody took a position
put their money on the line and say you
know what I think this market is going
that way I'm willing to buy you know
it's not something where you think well
I think the market could go here you
know when you follow the paper right
when you follow what's actually being
traded in the market
it shows you what people are actually
doing right they're actually committed
to that to the market to a position and
at some point they're also going to have
to get out either with a profit or with
the loss and you know it's that
commitment right because markets
basically you know is that the group
collective psychology or thinking of
where the market is you know relative to
value today and you know where they
predict it's going to be in the future
and you make a commitment based on that
and you know it's the way I describe it
sometimes for people is you know you go
to a you know if you're single if you're
single man you know you go to a bar to
to pick up a girl and a pretty girl
sitting over there and you sit there
till your friends you know you're
drinking your beer all that girl's so
pretty I'm gonna ask her out but you
never do right you're not committed to
it but once you get over there walk
start talking to her you know you're
committed to that you know that wants a
relationship but you know you're
committed to that action right now and
you know commitment in my opinion is
more stronger than intense right for
sure
I totally green it makes sense and and
and a lot of people end up following
retail traders and that just gets them
chopped up or everybody's looking at the
same indicator so I'm excited for your
presentation here I'm going to switch
you to an organizer here so you can see
the questions and then I'm going to
switch the screen over to anyone that
has any questions during Michaels
presentation please ask me in the box
there's a question box here on the go to
webinar control panel you can type in
two questions there and Michael will
either answer during your presentation
or at the end you know I'll talk for
about 10 minutes and I can ask some of
the questions that may or may he may not
have gotten to so I'll turn the screen
over to you you'll have about 30 minutes
Michael and I'll pick you back up after
that okay great
okay I should be showing my screen
everyone should be good to go
hopefully it's the right screen yup it
says it's got a 20/20 sign up there for
the new years there it is alright
alright thanks Jack talking a bit
alright everyone help welcome and you
know happy end of the year hopefully
this past year has been good to you in
the markets you know it's been really
nice to me and I'm always happy when you
get to the end of the year to look back
and you know sort of take stock over my
previous year's trading you know areas
that I did well in as well as areas that
I think need improvement and you know
it's not just a new year it's a new
decade so you know you really got to be
thinking big and you know everybody
likes to make new year's resolutions you
know lose weight quit smoking you know
make new friends but for traders it
should it be only one right improve your
trading results and honestly that's why
you're here right you want to always
improve yourself in life and especially
in trading and that's why if you stick
around to the end of the presentation
I'm going to give you a copy of my book
trading order flow it's 150 page book
that I wrote around the just a few years
ago now you know before I begin you know
just a brief disclaimer you know do
remember trading does involve risk you
know for some reason sometimes people
have this concept of you know it's a
race hour I got three months I got to
become a good trader in three months you
know trading takes time for some people
it takes three weeks for other peoples
it takes three months for other people
it takes three years you know just
understand that it's not a race against
time it's a race against yourself and
what your capacity for learning is so
you know as Jack had just mentioned
earlier my name is mike koval toes you
know i've basically been involved in the
futures industry since the early 90s I
started on the CMA floor as a runner for
Dean Witter really at the bottom of the
industry at the time eventually I moved
off the floors electronic trading was
taking off I stayed with Dean Witter
then the left for EDF man which is a big
English commodity trading firm been
around since the 1700s then I went to
work for Commerce Bank I was a licensed
uruk's trader I traded bullen's bobble
shots
zero stocks against the US products did
that for three years then I left that to
become a trading this manager at Cargill
where we traded all the commodities
around the world both futures as well as
cash markets after that I took about six
months off travelled a bit and I joined
JP Morgan where I spent eight years
there as vice president of futures
trading and after the birth of my first
child in twenty late December 2012 I
decided to leave JP Morgan and started
writing my book and trade for myself
then I started order flows about a year
or two after that now order flow is
something that I've always been involved
right as Jack is as much you know on the
trading floor the open outcry floor you
watch what is going on in the order flow
orders coming in you know what's behind
it if there's more buying or more
selling you know our locals being
aggressive and whatnot and I started
writing a book on order flow and I was
using an order flow chart from another
company and it was just a basic chart
which you know in the early 2000 you
know 12 2013 time you know was was good
enough that was a lot of information for
new traders to to grasp and but I knew
that there was more that I wanted to get
out of the software right I know that
software exists to help make your life
easier and you know there's ways that I
was analyzing the order flow for years
that I said you know what why don't I
just have the stuff programmed and
that's how the order flows trader and
order flows calm was born and you know
this is what an order flow chart looks
like and you know there's just so much
information that - the first time you
lay eyes on it you're like confused your
head is spinning you're gonna get a
headache
but hopefully by the end of this
presentation you should understand what
you're looking at now remember you know
what I'm presenting is what I built my
career on and hopefully you could find
or you can use things that you can
modify and adapt for your own trading
again you know just because I say it
doesn't necessarily mean it's true you
have to find the things that I say that
makes sense to you and adapt them for
your trading now just a disclaimer right
the charts that I use in this
presentation are
generated from my software the order
flows trader which runs on ninjatrader 8
you know the URL is there water flows
calm / all in dot html' so let's get
started right how to improve your
trading with order flow now when you
look at order flow chart the first time
but most people are fine now you know
it's it's really getting mainstream that
most people are familiar with what
they're looking at it order flow and
when you look at it it's a bit confusing
right because you don't really know what
to look at and to be honest when I
started on the sea before I was confused
as heck I didn't know where to begin and
you know some I was literally started as
a runner these gonna run this order into
the Japanese yen pit I was like where
the heck is that yeah it takes time to
adjust and learn but one thing I learned
pretty quick was if I want to be
successful I had to get over any fears
that I had and I had to learn how to
read the market now as we mentioned
earlier right order flow is two ways
there's two ways to look at order flow
and is it's an some people look at depth
of market which is the price ladder I
look at volume footprint chart and the
difference is depth of market is the
orders that are sitting in the order
book orders that are not filled they're
getting pulled they're getting moved
higher lower closer to the market
further from the market but they're not
traded yet now a volume footprint chart
which I just showed you is actual orders
that have traded and there is a big
difference right one shows commitment
one shows intention in my opinion
commitment is much more important than a
traders intention and once you have the
data you can put it into an easy to read
format and you can understand what's
happening in the market so we know that
markets trade in a two-way auction right
there's a bid price there's an offer
price and there's a quantity for the bid
price there's a quantity for the offer
price and a trade occurs when someone
either sells into the bid or buys from
the offer and the important thing is you
know when you buy from the offer or you
sell into the bid right you you're being
aggressive right if you're just sitting
on the bid and you're just sitting on
the offer if everybody's on the bid
everybody's on the offer no
it's gonna happen we're just passively
trading yeah I'll pay five dollars for
something but the other person is gonna
sell it at six well no one's no trades
going to happen you know we're both
passive you know I'm happy to pay five
you're happy to sell it at six one of us
has to be aggressive right one of us has
to either go down to five or go up to
six before the you know to get the trade
done and so there's a difference between
types of traders you know most people
just think of traders as just traders
but there's passive traders those are
the traders who buy on the bid or sell
on the offer they wait for the market to
come for them aggressive traders don't
wait for the market to come to them you
know they trade at the market they sell
in to the bid or they buy the offer
aggressive traders want to get a trade
done so once you understand the
differences between the different
traders and how they trade against each
other passive buyers versus aggressive
sellers passive sellers against
aggressive buyers then you can start to
interpret the footprint chart
all right the order flow now there are
to me there are three building blocks of
order flow footprint chart that you need
to know there's Delta there's imbalance
there's point of control so the Delta is
the net difference in the bar between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
okay if you have positive Delta means
you have more aggressive buyers than
aggressive sellers buyers are in control
if you have negative Delta sellers are
in control you have more aggressive
sellers than aggressive buyers and every
bar is going to have a delta delta could
be any number in the bar I mean you know
obviously is the difference could be
zero meaning it was evenly matched if
it's zero to me that's just more of a
coincidence it doesn't have any special
prediction powers now the next one is
imbalances and it occurs in the two-way
auction in between the volume traded on
the bid versus the volume traded on the
offer and generally I say generally
because there's a ratio people like to
look at if you have more aggressive
buyers than sellers by four to one then
you consider that in imbalance or more
aggressive sellers and buyers by four to
one you consider it an imbalance and you
could choose whatever number if you want
just two to one you can use that if you
want to use ten to one you can
use that but industry standards most
people use four to one I generally use
four to one
now you'll see on the bar in the
footprint right a buying imbalance is
blue color cell and imbalance is red
color and that's important especially at
turning points in the market if you
start seeing aggressive buying in the
form of imbalances at a low then you
know that aggressive buyers are stepping
up to the market they think the price is
low if you're at a high and you see
selling imbalances then you know there's
aggressive sellers up there at the high
and that's very valuable information
because if you know that hey at this low
price you know aggressive buyers are
stepping in chances are we're not going
to go lower right we're gonna start to
rally just as we'd sell off from a high
if you start seeing a flurry of
aggressive sellers coming in now the
last one is the point of control and
it's simply the level in the bar where
the most volume traded both on the bid
and the offer and there are times where
X fantastically as supply and demand
over the next bar and even bars so what
makes delta point of control and
imbalance is so powerful is there data
points generated by true market activity
right this is based on the buying and
selling occurring in the market and you
know there's no weird math involved in
it you know it's simple arithmetic you
know for point of control its volume
trade on the bid plus the volume traded
on the offer you add it up if it's the
most volume that's your point of control
the Delta you take the aggressive buyers
volume against the aggressive sellers
volume and you know you subtract it
whichever is the higher number it tells
you if it's positive or negative so
think of it like this right this does
you know in your car you have a
speedometer tells you how fast you're
accelerating or slowing down or derful
tells you how the market is moving up or
moving down you know is there strong
aggressive buying is there strong
aggressive selling is it weak aggressive
buying is it weak aggressive selling and
you know people always say order flow
allows you to see inside the bar which
it does but honestly what good is it if
you don't know
to look for right you have to know what
you're looking at to be able to
interpret it right you know if we go to
the doctor we have an x-ray done it's a
picture of your inside I could look at
it I don't know okay that's that's my
ribs I can't tell what I'm looking at
but a doctor could look at it and right
away I say oh you got this problem here
right he knows what to look at and the
same way with a volume footprint chart
you know with the order flow chart is
once you start to know what to look for
it becomes a lot easier to read and you
know when they say order flow allows you
to see inside the bar right when we get
to this low down here in this blue box
right now how do you know it's a good
buying opportunity
you know most traders would wait for
this market to rally up a bit before
they they start thinking that I eat this
markets in a rally but when you're down
here at the low right when you have
these lows being made you know you want
to know you know is this low going to
hold or are we going to go lower but if
you know how to read the order flow
you're gonna see by looking at the Delta
the point of controls the imbalances if
this low is going to hold and I can see
down here at this low that the Delta is
positive I know I've got net aggressive
buying coming in and what does that tell
me tells me I have buyers that are
actively taking over from the sellers
and at a low that's important because
you could have a shift in supply and
demand it could be going from a supply
driven market to all of a sudden a
demand driven market right and that's
what's gonna cause trends to happen is
shifts in supply and demand you know the
point of controls
I see our point of controls in each bar
subsequently getting higher right off
the low the next three bars higher
higher higher which tells me you know
we're sort of finding a new value areas
to the upside as this market is rallying
that tells me something very important
right it tells me this that the initial
value at the low is considered low the
next bar you have a higher value area
that's bullish then the next bar even
higher so you have three bullish pointed
controls there the imbalance is I see
right off this low you know I see two
bars with three buying imbalances in it
I
that's important information you know I
know I got positive Delta I know I got
buying imbalances in the bar I know I
got point of controls migrating higher
and what happens to the market it
rallies but I could know this right off
the bar off the low or the next bar off
the low if I'm still not convinced on
the low bar
that's what order flow allows you to do
you know concentrate by looking at Delta
appointed controls imbalances because
oftentimes the market will be revealing
itself in one of them or a combination
of them right it could be in the deltas
and imbalances it could be in point of
controls and imbalances it could be in
Delta or point of control so it could be
all three now this is a mini Dow five
minute chart and this is just from what
days two days ago people always ask me
you know hey I trade a longer term you
know can I use order flow and to be
honest I look at order for the longest I
look at it is five minutes I don't
really go beyond that I know some people
that do keep an eye on a 30-minute chart
in the order flow but really you know
you're basing your trades on what's
happening right now so if you're looking
at a you know 30 minute chart or a
longer hourly chart you know what's
happening right now sort of gets lost in
in the big mix I said about as long as
I'll go is five minutes I tend to stick
to you know range based charts and a
1-minute chart and markets like Nasdaq I
go down to a 30-minute chart so you know
we're rallying here in the mini Dow
right we make this high up here around
the 350 28 350 area and then we start to
come off go sideways then come off the
rest of the day down to 250 so it's
about a hundred point move you know
that's a nice move to have but you know
you want to look for signs in the order
flow that this market is going to be
selling off and when you start looking
at the actual volume footprint the
what's being traded in the market it
really becomes clear right what do you
have you have a new high being made
right at the high of the day and you got
negative Delta you've got aggressive
selling coming in okay which is bearish
and
it stays aggressive selling for one two
three four five six seven eight nine
bars you know it's a five-minute chart
so for an hour basically at the high of
the day you have aggressive selling what
do you think the markets gonna do they
think the markets gonna rally or it's
going to sell off we have so much
aggressive selling it's weighing on the
market eventually the selling is going
to overwhelm the buying right
the buyers can't get it any higher
because every time they try to poke it a
little bit higher aggressive selling
comes in now I have two boxes here I got
the blue box I've got the red box you
know the blue box is at your higher see
Delta is getting stronger in the
negative sense it goes from 70 to at the
high 128 169 so you know aggressive
selling is actually getting stronger as
you're making that high that's important
information to use as a trader and then
in this red box you have still negative
Delta's also getting stronger five minus
five minus 100 minus 175 but you also
have a line what I call aligned points
of controls I got three bars a 15-minute
period where the point of control is at
the same level right so I know it's
creating value and then we start trading
away from that to the downside I now
have a resistance level generated by
market information and why is that
important is because markets sold off we
rallied back right up to that level then
the market sold off right this is what
it looked like so you have a chance you
know at the high based on the order flow
with you know within three two to three
bars off the high to be getting short
other than a few bars later you have a
market generate at the level that if the
market comes back to it's an area for
you to be getting short market rally
back there got within you know traded
two ticks through that level before
immediately selling off or I imagine
right you have your higher they up here
at you know at 350 you have a offers in
here at 338 339
3:44 a move down to where you were
earlier you know at the to 30s to 40s we
don't when the cash market opened so
you're risking you know 10 15 ticks max
for what a potential 100 point move down
all right everyone always talks about
you gotta have good risk reward ratio
well you know that's how you get it
right you have these market generated
levels that you can hide behind you know
one of the questions all these people
have is why does the market sell-off
from a level right it's easy to look at
a chart after the fact and say yeah I
could have seen that market selling off
from there but you know as a trader you
want to be knowing as soon as you hit
that level what can the market sell off
from there so this is in the e-mini from
yesterday and you see we had to you know
like this double top here we sold off
each time all right you know the second
time it's maybe a little bit easier for
people because they'll say well we had a
double top you know we've tested it and
we sold off but what about the first
time you know is there any clues the
first time well there was in the order
flow you know and it was pretty clear
right you're at your new high of the day
you've got you know too bearish points
of controls together you know my order
flows trader software will actually
color in a point of control that it's
considered bearish based on you know my
analysis that's why I said you know I
like have order flow software that does
something besides just put up a plain
footprint chart and you know I've got a
delta divergence I have a new high with
negative Delta my software will also
color in that with a red triangle and I
have a bearish ratio that's this blue
number on top so I've got a lot of
things going on for this market up here
at this high telling me this market has
a potential to sell off next bar lower
next bar selling imbalances decks on
imbalances but all negative Delta right
so you can see how the first sell off
right the first high here number one was
able to get that sell off right now the
second time we got up to that high right
number two that we tested it well we
make an
hi bye you know about about a point and
then you just go sideways well what's
the clue in here that this market is
about to sell off you know it sideways
market eventually it's going to come out
of the consolidation it's going to come
out of going nowhere and you want to
have signs that you can trade off of an
order flow gives you that sign in the
Delta right you can see the first blue
box you have aggressive selling right
the negative Delta getting stronger so I
know there's at this hi there sellers in
up here okay but you know market doesn't
really sell off I do have some bearish
party controls but still going sideways
isn't quite yet making that sell-off and
then it looks like potentially we could
be going higher right I see Delta
positive Delta getting stronger
96 192 397 I got a bullish prominent
point of control well the market doesn't
go anywhere
selling reappears right after this
aggressive buying so what's happening
you got to be thinking you know as a
trader you have to think I know most
people don't like to think you know they
want to have everything computerized but
you know that's what's going to give you
you're an edge is your brain power and
you know if I see that ok aggressive
buyers are stepping up but the markets
not going higher then all of a sudden I
see aggressive selling coming in - 116 -
215 minus 298 you know that overrides
what I just thought literally five
minutes ago in the sense that I think
this markets going higher because
there's aggressive buying getting
stronger now I see aggressive selling
getting stronger I'm starting to see
selling imbalances starting to see
pointed controls go down lower lower
lower we're trading below you know we
got one two three four pointed controls
all aligned right at the same level
we're trading below that I know I got a
resistance level now forming at one it's
recorders we're trading below that I got
aggressive selling you know it's time to
be short alright and you see how the
market came off from that area right
here right who came down from you know
the one and a half the o2 area down
below 99 all right so that's that's how
order flow can help you see you know and
it's it's not brain set it's not rocket
science or anything like that it's just
simple
analysis you know by looking at what's
happening in the Delta the pointed
controls and the imbalances now you know
everyone likes to see signs in the
market you know what's happening you
know is there a sign here's a sign there
and this was in crude oil yes two days
ago and on Tuesday
right so you know we had our high came
off it test you know made another test
up then we came back here we got a lower
high and then late in the day you got
the big sell-off and
you know people like to draw trend lines
you know I used to draw trend lines too
and I used to trade off of them but you
know when they worked yeah I thought
they're the greatest things but often
times you know I'd have a trend line and
the market would just be hugging it you
know I'd have a trend line we'd break it
but then we just you know rally back up
break it a little bit rally back up you
know I found them kind of unreliable for
the most part and you know there's so
many different ways you could draw
levels honestly you know sometimes you
can just draw random levels and trade
around them but you know most people are
gonna say well this red line is the high
of the day that's my resistance area
where people will say well this Green
Line is you know this this intermediate
the swing high that's my resistance area
you know then people will draw a trend
line down the blue line you know
obviously we touched it once twice three
you know three times then people will
draw I got a rising trend line you know
the orange line going up you know
there's just so many different ways
there's four different lines I draw you
know which one you know after the fact
it's easy to say well yeah you got to
trade the orange one because it it sold
off but order flow if you were watching
the order flow you would know that the
60 88 level is quite important right you
can see we traded 60 88 it came right
back up that level before we sold off
okay and if you're watching the actual
footprint chart you could see the volume
that went through here at about 129 you
had 685 493 315 on the bid side three
three five seven eighty four 234 total
vol for this bar is you know 3200 they
got close to 2,000 Lots going through
around the 88 level right I mean one
tick above one tick below you know and
that's important to understand right you
if once you understand your market and
what's considered heavy volume honestly
the heavy volume of the the 685 and the
784 is enough information already but
you know when I look at you know when it
was bid and offered and bid and offered
above and below and I see the volumes
you know it really jumps out that's how
I know that hey you know this 88 level
is being defended at this level I got a
strong seller or sellers so if it comes
back there you know I want to know
what's going to happen you know it could
be a potential shorting opportunity so I
draw my line here at 88 and I see the
market comes right back up to that level
that is you know at 87 you trade look at
this volume 101 96 in granted this is a
2:00 in the afternoon right where
volumes aren't usually that great you
know 99 68 41 44 107 about 600 contracts
going through here at 87 again I know
this level is being defended so what are
you going to do right that's an area
that you want to get short you know if
it starts rallying okay that possibly is
gonna become my support area but I know
that we're coming up from down below
we're trading up into it so it's my
resistance area I've got sellers
reappearing great I can get short you
know you're getting short you know maybe
not getting short at 87 or 88 you know
are you getting short at 85 wait for the
market to come off a little bit 84 83
you know then what happens you start
hanging around going sideways before the
big drop down later in the day okay but
again this area right here at 1:30 in
the afternoon it's hidden right unless
you're looking at the order flow so you
know you what do you want to be looking
for in the order flow well obviously for
buys you want to have price movement in
the direction of your trade right if
you're buying if you're getting long you
want to have see them you know the bar
close up right you want a a green candle
so to speak
a bar that opens higher than a bar the
closes higher than an open you wanna
have a positive Delta parable you wanted
to be seen increasing Delta over you
know a few bars you want to be seen
higher points of control in each bar
you know preferably retest the previous
bars point of control you know and you
want to be seen buying a balances
appearing you know for sells it's the
opposite right you want to be seen price
movement in the direction in your trade
right you want to be seen red candles
red bars you want to be seen negative
Delta right you don't want to be buying
in a downward market with negative Delta
with red bars you know with lower points
of controls right because what's going
to happen is if I just gonna get run
over you're starting to get stopped out
right you want to be seen signs in the
order flow that this market could be
bottoming if you're looking to buy or at
a high you're gonna be looking for
reasons to sell right so if you're at
your high all of a sudden you see you
know a couple red bars you've seen
aggressive selling you've seen the
negative Delta's coming in you see
negative Delta is getting stronger as
you're going sideways but you're seeing
lower points of controls in each bar so
you know you know the volume that each
bar the value area is getting lower
right that's bearish and when you start
seeing selling imbalances also that's
bearish right so you can feel a bit more
confident of selling that high and you
know when you start to put the building
blocks of order flow together you have
something that's going to help you make
sense of the market it's going to go
from you know this on the left to that
on the right where you're able to put
stuff together and find trades so you
know when you start putting it together
for example this was crude oil right I
know that this is a good selling
opportunity right here at you know at
the 85 area because I got bearish
prominent point of controls right that's
the red point of controls their purple
rather I know I got weakening Delta
immediately after that I got points of
controls going down you know I know that
that's a safe sell for me you know for
buys right again you know I don't always
like to buy new highs even though the
market can go higher I
prefer to have reasons to sell at the
highest but when I see things that are
very bullish in the order flow you know
I just go with it
you know when I see bullish prominent
pointed controls that's these blue
pointed controls down here in the middle
right then I see that Delta increasing
you know it's gone 63 165 656 you know
as market moves up to 55 we go up from
55 all the way up to you know 77 over
the next few bars I see buying
imbalances coming in right I see in one
bar you know I see three buying
imbalances in itself the previous bar I
see two buying imbalances you know the
bar here at 8:01 so it's order flows
telling me hey you know what this market
is you know it's got more potential to
go higher you know people always wonder
why does this is a so this is a 30
minute chart right I just want to show
you this show you how people can use 30
minute chart you know and you see this
market pullback late in the day this is
Nasdaq we pull back to around the 82 97
area well then it rallies back up well
why because earlier you had this what we
call ThinPrint which is like a gap in
this big green candle up and oftentimes
you test that area right so imagine you
know you've got a gap in here right if
you know anything about gap theory at
some point you're looking for the market
to retest it and fill it and potentially
you know continue back in its original
direction and it did later in the day it
got within you know a couple of ticks
but hey you know what if you're trading
micros those new micro accounts you know
this is a great way to use order flow is
you know to look for these areas on
longer-term charts you know that offered
low risk behind opportunities because
you'd be buying it somewhere around the
Gap area you know you gotta remember
right if you're trading 40 points high
or trying to pick it to an exact level
is sometimes there's luck involved you
could come through it by you know a
couple points and then rally back up so
you probably want to scale that's why I
recommend you for a lot of people use
the micros because you could see easier
to scale contracts and to catch the move
back up you know you're talking in one
bar you know a 20 20 point rally off of
one bar now another thing order flow
gives
like we're talking about very early in
this conversation is following the paper
so I know right this is a minis were at
our high today is a five-minute chart
and we would get up to the high of the
day I could see the Delta very strong -
mm - mm - 1400 I know there's strong
sellers and they're big sellers coming
into the market I know I got selling
imbalances you know that's the order
flow coming into the market telling me
hey there's aggressive sellers up here
you want to possibly get out of any
Long's that you're in and seriously
think about getting short and then you
know the market starts drifting sideways
and then starts heading down for the
rest of the day now hopefully by now you
should be able to see how using the
three pieces of order flow Delta pointed
controlling imbalances can give you
great trading opportunities you just
need to know what to look for and it
does help to have software that has the
ability to highlight that for you again
if you're interested you go to my
website order flows calm I got a lot of
great information on there and honestly
we've only just scratched the surface on
how to use order flow there's so many
ways that you can use order phone now
and you know something people don't
realize is how hedge funds are using
order flow analysis as well you know
it's not just you know retail traders
sitting at home you know hedge funds are
data mining Delta point of control
imbalances and other aspects of order
flow so you know if you're not adapting
order flow into your trading you know I
think you're leaving a lot of
information on the table that other
people are going to use and get an edge
over you so if you're interested you can
get my book go to order flows calm slash
book HTML it's going to take you to this
page you have to enter your first and
last name and your email address then
you hit submit then it'll take you to a
page that it'll download for you so you
know is people always ask me well what
was the big turning point in my life you
know it was a Friday afternoon on the
floor there's about one hour left in the
day
I've also turned to me my pasta turned
to me and said well toast it's your turn
you know meaning get up start quoting me
the market we're gonna start trading my
reply was what can we start Monday you
know because I sort of
you know I had some fears honestly I
wanted everything to be perfect before
getting started but in life you have to
take imperfect actually right you have
to be committing committed to what
you're going to do right I tell you this
because the best way to Ornt learn order
flow is to just jump in right but yet
should have proper training nowadays
there's great training available in the
past that really wasn't but more
importantly you got to be committed
right you know you're at the altar those
that are married you know sometimes you
have fears you know now you know I admit
sometimes I had my fears too but I was
committed right I've now got a beautiful
family I've got three kids and I'm happy
and you know trading has given me that
opportunity and it can give you that
opportunity as well so Jack I'll throw
it back to you see if there's any
questions hey Michael great presentation
I always love listening to your story
and in the order flow if anybody has any
questions feel free to add them in here
I'm gonna read some off here so does
your order flow software for NT eight
work with playback connection yes it's a
market replay so you could watch it you
know you could speed it up there's you
know like a thousand times as fast so
because you know you sit in front of the
screen it's like thick I tick you know
so you can you can speed it up yeah it I
think it's called the market replay but
yeah it does
and I know usually the question that
follows is does it work you know does
this type of analysis work with Forex
and stocks it does with stocks but it
needs to be stocks that are actively
traded and have good volume because
after all you're analyzing volume you
know if you're analyzing say penny
stocks or not you know not highly
capitalized stocks you know you get
these days where there's a lot of volume
then most days there's you know market
is very quiet and there's little volume
so it's really hard to get a grasp on it
but you know big stocks like Apple is
one that I follow with order flow and it
makes follows order flow nicely
but for X you know for X you have
decentralized exchanges in the sense
that you know the data doesn't come from
oneexchange the way it does from CME or
C BOTS or nymex so you know oftentimes
you're getting just a white label from
you know Barclays or Goldman Sachs or JP
Morgan and the data that you're getting
comes from a completely different source
so you know you're sort of trading you
know a different quote then then sort of
what's what's really out there so you
can trade see amy has euro currencies
they've got British Pound Japanese yen
so that there are futures contracts on
currencies which for me
you know make perfect sense right gotcha
okay so next question here somebody's
asking this is Sam is asking may I know
how your Advanced Course compares to the
basic course okay well you know just
recently I released an advanced course
and you know basic courses for people
that are relatively new to order flow
you know and don't really understand
things like absorption or even Delta
pointed controls things like that
whereas the Advanced Course or you know
it's a step further beyond just the
basic stuff because yeah I realized now
you know over the last few years a lot
of traders have been turned on to order
flow right so they really understand the
basics and you know I wanted something
out there that was just a bit more
advanced that you know traders can sort
of sink their teeth into all right they
understand the basics you know it's like
riding a bicycle you know how to sit on
a bicycle balance and ride it but now
you want to do the the wheelies and
stuff you know so to speak got it got it
make sense so um let's see last question
here says can you please exchange
explain briefly the significance of
min/max Delta and how it's calculated oh
no that's that's fine you know there's
there's Delta there's finals belts
others max Delta there's min Delta and
it'll appear on the bottom and basically
max Delta tells you how positive Delta
was at its highest level in the bar min
Delta tells you how strong negative
Delta was
a particular point in the bar and there
are times where you know the
relationship between the two is very
important like for example if you're at
your height of the day and you had at
one point early in the bar very strong
max telethon you know there's very
strong aggressive mind but the bar close
with negative Delta and you see that
it's you know min Delta we close
somewhere near there so you know that
internally in that bar you had strong
aggressive buying but you know like here
in this chart that the high we got
positive Delta to 466 max Delta of three
276 min delta of 118 so max Delta the
maximum buying and there was three to
seven six we closed at two four six 6
min Delta was only 118 but there's times
where you see max delta of 3,000 276
final delta and min delta is probably a
big negative number like minus two four
six six so imagine what's going on it
went from positive 3,000 aggressive
buyers to negative 2,000 aggressive
sellers so it's actually a swing of
5,000 so that's that's very important
information that's covered in my courses
okay
got it also Donna saying excellent
content thank you so much I agreed on it
so it was an amazing presentation I want
to point out here in the chat window if
you go if you're on your GoToWebinar
control panel and you go look at the
chat window you'll see a link the one
that Michael had up on the screen there
here's clickable here you can just click
its WW order flows comm Forge slash book
dot HTML simply fill out your
information and you're gonna get a free
copy of his order book here as well I
highly recommend it
I mean I'm biased being a floor trader
and having been a Chicago trader and
work with so many people that Michael
worked with as well but I love this
strategy and love the style of trading
and I think it's amazing and I've seen
so many people be successful at this
strategy bursa lot of other strategies
that I love it as close to my heart I
love what Michaels doing he's got the
right attitude in terms of how he
teaches people he's all about giving
back and all about making sure people
succeed so I would strongly recommend
clicking that link water flows calm
poured slash book dot html' putting your
information and download that free book
and get started there with Michael today
so Michael any last thoughts before you
go no you know just everyone have a
great holiday enjoy the time off you
know it
you know for most people they're on
break from work it's great chance to
spend time with your family and at
nighttime you know learn more about the
markets you know you always want to
improve yourself in in trading there's
no ceiling downtime during the holidays
lots of downtime people usually have
right there's only so much you can talk
to exactly alright well have a great
holiday and wishing you an amazing and
safe new year and the best for 2020
Michael you too jack thank you thank you
being on the show bye